Andy's taking me to his office right now
this is special this is not your office
this is going anywhere this is going
decorator I can see the function
happening so great okay
hey guys it is Thursday here on it's
grace and it is a tipsy Thursday where
we give you tips but also yeah cheers
Cheers
yeah we just did want to have his life
and it was fantastic and so Andy yes
these are great angles gypsy Thursday 60
Thursday so I want to ask you what is
your advice on hosting a television show
what would I know I don't know I mean
pinstripes is number one is a strike
yeah oh you know what one thing is yeah
which I don't always do I did tonight
which was bad try not to yawn on the
show I are hosting your own show it's so
funny you think that I literally yond in
a video the other day like I caught it
right there contagious but also it makes
you seem like you're not interesting
yeah your own show I'm be on the other
Island Sandra Bernhard was on come like
a couple months ago but I let out a big
one and she was like whoa many yonward
I own better than a fart yes oh my god
definitely don't mark yeah by the way
once and this is a daily grace exclusive
it's grace oh oh my god it's a nice
great it's very exclusive yeah but once
actually I've done like 550 shows maybe
575 like not a real
I know it's easy and there was one time
and I wish that I could remember who the
guests were but right before the show
started I farted literally like like
audibly or second no ass SBD and I then
started welcoming my guests and I was
literally looking at her it was a woman
it was a housewife
I just remembered who I was I just
remember I'm not going to tell you it
was and I literally and by the way it
was like a fancy house it was not like
it was it Louie that's the moment you
don't like when you were were you told
when you were a child that if you pee in
the pool it turns purple sometimes oh
okay maybe this is something weird that
my parents told me when it's a child
that their pools have this thing and I
guess like big public pools have this
thing that like if someone pisses in the
pool it like changes the pH balance
smart thing to tell a kid right right
notice you wouldn't I once I heard that
I was like well there goes my days of
pissing in the pool but yeah thank God
that doesn't happen for farts also maybe
you might get some charcoal underwear oh
you're gonna charcoal on your way no
it's it filters your farts Wow yeah I
know a lot about little tube like I may
as well just wear a diaper I don't
ultimately have a problem passing gas oh
yeah don't that's not really no but I
like I really can control it yeah that's
what I want you that except that one
time right before me yeah I do feel like
one of my special skills is controlling
my gas outtake yeah okay so no yawning
no farting right what would be the third
most important rule of hosting your own
Oh ciao smile don't forget to smile you
know who I heard say that Rachael Ray
yeah yeah she said that the greatest
advice she ever got is smile even when
you think you're being ridiculous
ha ha yeah I think that's true I gave a
friend of mine was on a show the other
day for the first time and I go you know
what just smile a lot Rachael Ray got
pretty drunk on my show
yes she did oh my favorite show is when
Kelly Ripa got John and she just kept
being like yeah she's like a symbol of
champagne we got always smile you always
want the audience to think you're having
a great day that's true even if you're
really just farting right well that's
great Andy thank you so much for your
advice
thank you yeah make sure that you guys
go subscribe to their YouTube channel
over here on YouTube because you guys
have been YouTube oh yeah WW HL is that
what the YouTube thing is is it you just
got powned /ww HL yeah it is ok either
way guys just google it and find out
looking disheveled mess this is what it
looks like when you are in New York City
hey guys okay so uh I had the greatest
time on watch what happens live tonight
uh Jerry O'Connell and I should shot so
like my bucket list is basically just
like pale with like pale is smaller than
a bucket maybe I don't know but there's
a couple things I wanted to remind you
of one camp Takota com.com
slash edu and to memory and I are doing
a show in Boston and we have a super
secret guest it's gonna be part of the
show that you guys are gonna love and we
can't announce it because it's you know
hashtag secret and then also I don't
think I meant and we're back I don't
think I mentioned this week to go check
out Grace's faces there's a brand new
episode last Friday on the I love makeup
Channel please go check that out and
then I think that's it for all of my
shout outs
guys New York is fun and also gross and
cold and fun yeah the fun makes you
forget about the fact that there's like
a thin layer of pee on everything in
this city which I've told you before
good talk